cool job at bronzer self like a recently
released prison inmate that's trying to
rehabilitate themselves by taking people
on tours of the prison I'm really into
contours what does this and that have in
common both are a stretch hello guys my
name is grace Helbig if you don't know
that is my name
recently a lot of people have been
obsessed with the kylie jenner lip
challenge according to society Kylie
Jenner has huge lips and also according
to society you can bypass surgery to get
those huge lips by taking a shot glass
and putting it around your mouth and
sucking in for a long time until your
lips get huge and this has become quite
a controversy you know what else is a
controversy the fact that my dog's not
in this room but a reeks of recent farts
in this world where there are a lot of
people everyone wants to look prettier
than the other person and in this world
where you don't know if you're gonna die
tomorrow no one wants to waste any time
so why not put this on your face and
suck it in until your lips look like
something society says is sexy I
consider myself a part of society
occasionally I'm infinitely curious
about science moderately and I love
feeling like I'm a part of something
therefore today I will be partaking in
the Kylie Jenner lip challenge to see
what really happens let's do it
well you know as a host of the shot
glass it would be just very rude of me
not to showcase its talents
wow you are fascinating as a guest let's
do this oh my god forgot to put my
parents
oh my god I forgot to forget to call my
parents what an idiot
let's do this oh my god I forgot that
I'm supposed to stand here let's do this
and take an Instagram donate that filter
why did I choose it hmm how can I go
look when I'm doing this you know this
is so tiny and it supposed to expedite
surgery what did I just use a bigger
mouth glass and that expedites this
whole process yeah doesn't work this one
tastes like soap oh my god this is my
expensive candle I want to like this as
a candle instead oh my god I hate myself
for not thinking of that first this
isn't working and this one smells like
shoes back to basics I'm hungry
can't eat when I do this oh my god I
love this song but what if I want to
talk and do this at the same time this
sucks
did that do anything
- buh uh-oh
go stat support positive body image
you're back
oh my god I forgot I should be
challenging myself to make my future
bigger oh I don't know don't forget to
watch my television show the grace
Helbig show this Friday on e at 10:30
p.m. Abby Lee Miller and Paul Scheer
talk about things worth spending your
time on